Cola die Welt im Griff ich bin in der
Hauptstadt der Cola Trinker in San
Christobal 160 l pro Kopf trinken die
hier pro Jahr die Kombination aus Zucker
und Koffein Verleih uns einen ganz
speziellen dreifachkick Sebastian baut
Coca-Cola nach und reist für eine
heilige Zeremonie nach
Mexiko das hier ist die berühmteste
Limonade der Welt Coca-Cola und da drin
steckt einer der genialsten Tricks der
Lebensmittelindustrie PR
Coca-Cola hat's erfunden und alle machen
es nach das nenne ich mal
Erfolgsgeschichte was steckt dannn so im
Original Wasser Zucker Kohlensäure
Farbstoff Phosphorsäure natürliches
Aroma Aroma
Koffein sechs Zutaten ein mega Erfolg
wie kann es sein dass ein Getränk in
jeder Nation der Erde beliebt ist in
manchen sogar beliebter als Wasser
in Deutschland verkauft die Coca-Cola
Company 40 l Cola pro Kopf und
Jahr in den USA trinken die Menschen
mehr als 90
l und weltweiter Spitzenreiter beim
colakonsum ist Mexico gut 140 l
Coca-Cola kaufen die Menschen hier pro
Kopf und
[Musik]
jah lege reist in den Süden von Mexiko
hier ist der colakonsum noch einmal
höher als im Rest des
Landes ich bin in der Hauptstadt der
colrinker in San chisto bal 160 l pro
Kopf trinken die hier pro Jahr WoW und
was das mit der Gesundheit anstellt das
schaue ich mir jetzt mal
an coca-Cola ist in San Christobal
allgegenwärtig
abgefüllt wird sie direkt vor Ort der
Konzern nutzt Trinkwasser dass er sich
zu besonders günstigen Preisen gesichert
hat gleichzeitig hat die ärmere
Bevölkerung in San Christobal selten
Zugang zu sauberem Wasser auch deshalb
kaufen die Menschen hier abgefüllte
Getränke aus der Fabrik ich bin gleich
bei den absoluten cocac-cola Fans und da
gehört sich das ein Kasten Cola
mitzubringen aber nicht die einfache
coloha aus der Plastikflasche nein nein
die guten aus Glas sollen sein und die
bekomme ich hier
hallo Boxer
Coca-Cola mein Spanisch istich sehr
schlecht Sebastian lege findet
massenhaft Coca-Cola wen eine ganz Party
werden soll
ne 3
l 3 l colafasche habe ich noch nie in
meinem Leben gesehen
wie in Deutschland ist Coca-Cola aus der
Glasflasche etwas
teurer ist das schwer aber richtig
schwer das Geschenk ist bereit
verglichen mit Deutschland ist Coca-Cola
in Mexico ein echtes Luxusprodukt
umgerechnet etwa 2,15
kostet hier der halbe Liter bei einem
Monatseinkommen von dem Schnitt gerade
mal knapp 800
[Musik]
präente in einem Vorort von San
Christobal besucht Sebastian lege
Rosaria in ihrer
Heimwerkstatt gemeinsam mit ihren beiden
Tanten stellt sie Souvenirs für
Touristen
her Cola ist bei der Arbeit immer mit
dabei warum trinkt ihr so gerne
Coca-Cola weil sie gut schmeckt weil sie
süß ist
trinkt ihr nur Cola oder trinkt ihr auch
mal
Wasser nein wir trinken nur cocac-cola
die hat einfach mehr Geschmack als
Wasser wisst ihr wie viel zuckerca
enthält der Zucker ist uns
egal wir trinken einfach gerne
Cola Z bis D Flaschen Coca-Cola trinken
die Frauen pro Tag so wie viele Menschen
in
Mexiko ist tief im Rezept der Coca-Cola
versteckt die beiden Besserwisser Lil
Temme und Florian reser erklären es gibt
eine geheime Formel die alle colamarken
[Musik]
ein L auf eine Cola
klar haben Sie sich eentlich auch schon
mal gefragt warum ausgerechnet diese
braune Brühe hier dasiebte Getränk der
Welt ist das liegt am Zucker gleich 12
Würfel stecken in so einer Dose und die
bescheren unserem Körper gleich einen
dreifachen Kick Kick Kick Kick
hurra nach 10 Minuten kommt der erste
Zucker in unserem Blut
an um all diesen Zucker sinnvoll zu
verarbeiten leistet unser Körper
allerdings
schwerstarbeitem die Leber den
überschüssigen Zucker
[Musik]
einspeichert
nach etwa 40 Minuten kommt das Koffein
im Körper
an Aufmerksamkeit und
Konzentrationsvermögen nehmen zu das
Schlafbedürfnis nimmt ab einfach
anregend dummerweise findet das auch die
Leber angeregt durch das ganze Koffein
fängt sie an den gerade erst
eingespeicherten Zucker wieder zurück
ins Blut abzugeben und innerhalb von
kürzester Zeit erlebt unser Körper den
zweiten
zuckerkick 45 Minuten nachdem wir die
Cola getrunken haben schüttet unser
Körper das Glückshormon Dopamin
aus und plötzlich geht alles viel viel
leichter von der Hand der Körper liebt
das und der Trick mit dem Kick
funktioniert dort besonders gut wo
Leitungswasser nicht sicher
[Musik]
ist seit dem 2000 ist der colakonsum in
Mexiko um 60 l pro Kopf
gestiegen gleichzeitig hat sich die Zahl
der Diabetesfälle mehr als verdreifacht
auf 14,1 Millionen im Jahr
2021 Sebastian lege trifft Fermin
regadas seine Initiative kämpft gegen
die Ursachen der diabetespandemie in
Mexiko in Mexiko gibt es in jeder
Familie jemanden der an Diabetes
erkrankt ist der ein Bein verloren hat
erblindet ist oder aufgrund von Diabetes
gestorben
ist mehr als 150 000 Menschen sterben in
Mexiko jedes Jahr an Diabetes zahlreiche
Studien weisen nach es ist die viele
Cola die krank
macht doch coca-Cola ist im Verlauf
weniger Jahrzehnte fester Bestandteil
der mexikanischen Kultur und sogar der
Religion geworden Sebastian lege besucht
einen der zahlreichen Priester bei denen
die Menschen Rat und göttlichen Beistand
suchen
h Coca-Cola spielt in der mexikanischen
Kirche eine wichtige Rolle als eine Art
heiliges Getränk Sebastian lege erlebt
wie so eine colaeremonie
abläuft dein Name Sebastian
Sebastian in den nächsten 20 Minuten
betet Priester otavio für die Gesundheit
und das Wohlergehen von Sebastian
[Musik]
lege erst die
[Applaus]
Beschwörungsformeln dann setzt der
Priester Coca-Cola ein er schreibt dem
Getränk eine höhere Macht
zu Coca-Cola CocaCola vertreibt Trauer
und Sorgen wenn du traurig bist dann
beschützt Cola dich das ist der Grund
warum wir Sie bei der Zeremonie
einsetzen deshalb geben wir sie auf der
Erde und opfern sie den
Göttern cocac-cola hat den Segen von
ganz oben
steckt der Konzern selbst
dahinter das zeigt wie effektiv das
Marketing von Coca-Cola ist sie
erreichen die Orte an denen es kein
Trinkwasser und keinen Strom
gibt wenn sie in die Kirche gehen spielt
Coca-Cola bei den Zeremonien eine Rolle
wenn eine Gemeinde ein Bußgeld erhebt
dann wird die Strafe mit einer Kiste
Cola bezahlt die man dann für die
nächste Party verwenden
kann
coca-Cola hat die indigenen Gemeinden im
Hochland von chppas komplett in der
Hand eine ikonische Flasche ein
weltbekannter Schriftzug und ein
dreifach Kick aus Zucker und Koffein das
ist das Erfolgsgeheimnis von
Coca-Cola to to to to kurze
Werbeunterbrechung in eigener Sache
herzlich willkommen zu unserer
besseresserhow hier im Studio Spiel
Spaß und Schokolade wo bleiben die res
kan Nüsse und Spuren von Kinderarbeit
enthalten die erste Folge die gibt's
hier bei YouTube und alle anderen könnt
euch in der ztf Mediathek anschauen so
schaut gerne mal rüber oder rein ja oder
schaut euch einfach Werbung
[Musik]
Ende mit dazu gibt es ein Lebensgefühl
Werbung ist die Paradedisziplin von
Coca-Cola auf der ganzen
Welt
[Musik]
und noch ein genialer Trick von
Coca-Cola die haben aus dem
Weihnachtsmann einen Popstar gemacht
fröhliche Weihnachten der Weihnachtsmann
verdankt sein berühmtes Outfit der
Coca-Cola Company die hat auch die
Farben Rot und Weiß zu den typischen
Weihnachtsfarben gemacht das hat nichts
mit Überlieferung zu tun t sondern
beruht auf dem Marketing von Coca-Cola
und damit nicht genug das Unternehmen
produziert jedes Jahr einen neuen
aufwendigen
weihnachtswerbespot die haben viele
Dinge einfach als erstes gemacht im
Markt die haben es geschafft dass die
Menschen nicht nur im Sommer ein
Erfrischungsgetränk trinken sondern auch
im Winter indem sie ganz groß das Thema
Weihnachten in der Kommunikation spielen
die waren die Erfinder des Sixpacks ja
und haben damit im Grunde genommen es
möglich gemacht dass die Leute
Coca-Cola zu Hause getrunken haben ja
weil sie im Sixpack mehr mitnehmen
konnten jahrzehntelang hat der Konzern
seine eigene Geschichte erzählt der
Erfolg beruhe angeblich auf dem
einzigartigen Geschmack das hier ist der
heilige Gral das Coca-Cola Aroma
über 100 Jahre ist die Cola Formel alt
sie spült jedes Jahr Milliardengewinne
in die Kasse der Coca-Cola
Muttergesellschaft
[Musik]
alles beginnt im Jahr
1886 in Atlanta damals erfindet der
Apotheker John Smith pamperton ein
Getränk gegen Müdigkeit und
Kopfschmerz er verkauft das Rezept und
die Patentrechte wenig später an AC g
Chandler der gründet die Coca-Cola
Company von Anfang an investiert er viel
Geld in
[Musik]
Werbung die Rezeptur wird wie ein
Staatsgeheimnis behandelt angeblich gibt
es nur zwei Menschen auf der Welt die
sie kennen ein geschickter Mythos
bereits im Jahr
1979 veröffentlichte eine Zeitschrift in
Atlanta pampetens
Originalrezept darin enthalten sind
Aromen von Orange Limone oder Koriander
außerdem ein flüssiges Extrakt der
Kokapflanze mit Kokain 1914 wird die
Cola Rezeptur angepasst Koffein ersetzt
Kokain und im Laufe der Jahre gibt es
weitere Veränderungen das Rezept hat
heute kaum noch etwas mit dem Original
zu tun das wahre Erfolgsgeheimnis von
Coca-Cola liegt gar nicht im Aroma
sondern in der Kombination von Zucker
und Koffein bei Coca-Cola und den
nacharmern Coca-Cola schmeckt sogar von
Kontinent zu Kontinent anders in den USA
ist Coca-Cola mit einer anderen Variante
erfolgreich als in
Südamerika in
Asien oder in Europa und das liegt am
Zucker Post in Coca-Cola werden auf der
ganzen Welt verschiedene Zuckerarten
verwendet in Amerika mairup in
Südamerika Rohrzucker und bei uns in
Deutschland
Zuckerrüben hier steckt so 20% Zucker
drinne und den holen wir jetztaus die
Zuckerarten schmecken ganz
unterschiedlich Sebastian lege hchelt
für deutsche Cola Zuckerrüben klein und
lässt sie stundenlang weich kochen
dadurch löst sich all der Zucker im
Wasser danach muss der Produktentwickler
das Zuckerwasser aus den
herauspressen Schritt 1 der
Zuckerproduktion ist geschafft mehr als
200 Jahre ist das Verfahren alt und wird
nach wie vor genutzt das ist so klebrig
das können sich gar nicht vorstellen
alles klebt klebt klebt klebt Kochen mit
Unterdruck bis heute wird Zucker nach
diesem Prinzip gewonnen denn durch
Unterdruck verdampft Wasser nicht erst
bei 100 sondern schon bei 60° das spart
Energie und
Zeit
da ist ja nichts mehr drin im
Topf dieser Sirup besteht nun schon zu
etwa 70% aus Zucker Sebastian lege will
an die reinen Kristalle kommen und mit
einem D Automaten auch noch das letzte
bisschen Wasser
loswerden Zeit für ein
Päuschen sieht ja
keiner
[Musik]
sieht richtig gut aus und macht die Cola
zuckerüß fehlt noch der original
colafbstoff auch der ist aus
[Musik]
Zucker die Industrie versetzt Ammoniak
und Schwefelsäure mit Zucker Sebastian
lege ersetzt die Chemikalien durch
Essigessenz die hat fast denselben
Effekt und die Dämpfe sind nicht ganz so
giftig und jetzt wird der Zucker
kontrolliert verbrannt
feuerfrei ich nehme ein bisschen Abstand
weil die Dämpfe können hart auf die
Lunge gehen und das ist nicht ganz so
schön so es geht los oh oh oh oh ich
muss Maske aufsetzen Maske aufsetzen
trotz der gefährlichen Zutaten gilt
Zuckercouleur als gesundheitlich
unbedenklich der Farbstoff ist nicht ein
mehr süß sogar in Diet Coke oder Coke
Zero darf er eingesetzt
werden kurzer Test ob die Färbekraft
auch ausreicht hier normales
Wasser perfektes
schwarz weiterer Trick von Coca-Cola die
transportieren ja nicht fertige
Coca-Cola in alle Herren
Länder es wird nur der reine Coca-Cola
Sirup hergestellt und vor Ort einfach
mit Wasser und Kohlensäure versetzt und
fertig ist das Trinkerlebnis die
Herstellung von colasirup ist denkbar
einfach Zucker Koffein und Phosphorsäure
mit Zuckercouleur mischen umrühren
abkühlen
lassen das angeblich so geheime
colaaroma dazu geben und fertig ist das
Konzentrat das Coca-Cola um die Welt
schickt da machen wir ein bisschen Cola
oder in den Apfelanlagen der Industrie
passiert genau dasselbe wie in Sebastian
leges sodasprudler allein in Deutschland
sind es 14 Standorte an denen der
Konzern seine Limonaden von
Partnerfirmen abfüllen
lässt die Cola schäumt schon mal wie das
Original
das ist der echte Coca-Cola
[Musik]
Effekt
süß dank cleverem Marketing macht
Coca-Cola Milliarden
Gewinne die Kosten die die Behandlung
von Karies Übergewicht oder Diabetes
verursachen bezahlen Steuerzahler rund
um den
Globus mittlerweile Steuern erste
Regierungen
[Musik]
gegen es ist also wirklich eine
Überlegung wert ob eine
süßgetränkeabgabe oder eine Zuckersteuer
dazu beitragen würde dass die Menschen
gesündere Produkte zu sich nehmen
England hat 2018 eine Zuckersteuer auf
softdinks eingeführt seitdem hat sich
der Zuckergehalt von Fanta Sprite und
vielen anderen Getränken der Coca-Cola
Company im Schnitt
halbiert
nur bei Cola ändert sich nichts trotz
Strafsteuer bleibt der Zuckergehalt
unverändert hoch so lässt der Trick mit
dem Kick auch in Zukunft die Gewinne
sprudeln
na sind sie immer noch ein kleiner Cola
Junky